Ils devraient travailler sur les lieux, les gens et les paysages
que le mur met en danger.
Les gens se montrent à la hauteur de la situation,
et si l'objectif du mur est de maintenir les gens à distance,
il réunit les gens de façons remarquables,
organisant des évènements mondains tels que des cours de yoga binationaux
pour réunir les gens par-delà ce clivage.
J'appelle cela la pose monument.
(Rires)
Avez-vous entendu parler de « wall y ball » ?
C'est une version frontalière du volleyball pratiquée depuis 1979
(Rires)
le long de la frontière
pour célébrer l'héritage binational.
Cela soulève des questions intéressantes.
Un tel jeu est-il légal ?
Se passer une balle par-dessus le mur constitue-t-il du commerce illicite ?
(Rires)
La beauté du volleyball est qu'il transforme le mur
en rien de plus qu'une ligne dans le sable
négociée par les esprits, les corps et les âmes des joueurs des deux côtés.
Je pense que c'est exactement ce genre de négociations bilatérales
qui sont nécessaires pour faire tomber les murs qui divisent.
Lancer la balle au-dessus du mur est une chose,
mais jeter des pierres au-dessus du mur
a causé des dommages à des véhicules de patrouille frontalière
et a blessé des agents de patrouille frontalière
et la réponse du côté américain a été drastique.
Les agents de patrouille frontalière ont tiré à travers le mur,
tuant du côté mexicain des gens qui lançaient des pierres.
Une autre réponse des agents de patrouille
est d'ériger des filets d'arrêt de baseball
pour se protéger, eux et leurs véhicules.
Ces filets d'arrêt sont devenus une installation permanente
lors de la construction de nouveaux murs.
J'ai commencé à me demander si, comme le volleyball,
le baseball devrait devenir une caractéristique de la frontière
et les murs pourraient s'ouvrir,
permettant aux communautés de traverser et de venir jouer
et s'ils réalisent un home run,
un agent de patrouille pourrait ramasser la balle et la renvoyer
de l'autre côté de la frontière.
Un agent de patrouille frontalière achète un raspado, un dessert glacé,
à un vendeur à quelques mètres,
nourriture et argent sont échangés à travers le mur,
un événement complètement normal rendu illégal par une ligne tracée sur une carte
et quelques millimètres d'acier.
Cette scène m'a rappelé un dicton :
« Si vous avez plus que nécessaire, vous devriez avoir des tables plus grandes
et pas des murs plus hauts. »
J'ai créé ce souvenir pour rappeler le moment où nous pouvions
partager de la nourriture et avoir une conversation par-delà le clivage.
Un système de balancement permet à quelqu'un d'aller de l'autre côté
jusqu'à ce que la gravité les déporte dans leur pays.
La frontière et le mur frontalier
sont aujourd'hui vus comme une sorte de théâtre politique,
alors peut-être devrions-nous inviter le public à ce théâtre,
à un théâtre binational où les gens se réunissent
avec des acteurs, des musiciens.
Peut-être que le mur n'est rien de plus qu'un énorme instrument,
le plus grand xylophone au monde, et nous pourrions jouer sur le mur
avec des armes de percussion de masse.
(Rires)
Quand j'ai imaginé cette bibliothèque binationale,
je voulais imaginer un espace où l'on pourrait partager
des livres, des informations, des connaissances par-delà un clivage,
où le mur n'était rien de plus qu'une étagère.
Peut-être que la meilleure façon d'illustrer notre relation mutuelle
entre le Mexique et les États-Unis
est en imaginant une balançoire,
où les actions d'un côté ont une conséquence directe
sur ce qu'il se passe de l'autre côté,
car la frontière même
est à la fois un pivot symbolique et littéral
pour les relations américano-mexicaines
et construire des murs entre voisins rompt ces relations.
Vous vous souvenez sûrement de cette citation :
« Les bonnes clôtures font les bons voisins. »
C'est souvent vu comme étant la morale du poème « Mending Wall » de Robert Frost.
Mais en fait, le poème questionne le besoin de bâtir des murs.
C'est un poème sur le rétablissement des relations humaines.
Mon vers préféré est celui-ci :
« Il y a quelque chose qui n'aime pas un mur. »
Car s'il y a une chose qui est claire à mes yeux --
il n'y a pas deux côtés définis par un mur.
Il y a un paysage, divisé.
D'un côté, cela ressemble à ceci.
Un homme tondant sa pelouse avec le mur se profilant dans son jardin.
Et de l'autre côté, cela ressemble à ceci.
Le mur est le quatrième mur d'une maison.
Mais en réalité, le mur pénètre la vie des gens.
Il pénètre nos propriétés privées,
nos terrains publics,
nos terres amérindiennes, nos villes,
une université,
nos quartiers.
Je n'ai pas pu m'empêcher de me demander
quel serait le résultat si le mur passait dans une maison.
Rappelez-vous des disparités entre richesse et pauvreté.
Sur la droite, la taille moyenne d'une maison à El Paso, Texas,
et à gauche la taille moyenne d'une maison à Juarez.
Ici, le mur passe au milieu de la table de la cuisine.
Ici, le mur passe au milieu du lit dans la chambre.
Car je voulais communiquer comment le mur ne divisait pas que des lieux,
qu'il séparait des gens, qu'il séparait des familles.
La politique malheureuse du mur
est, aujourd'hui, de séparer les enfants de leurs parents.
Vous connaissez peut-être ce panneau de signalisation.
Il a été conçu par un graphiste, John Hood,
un vétéran de guerre amérindien
travaillant pour les transports publics en Californie.
Il avait pour tâche de créer un panneau pour avertir les automobilistes
des immigrants sur les bords de l'autoroute
qui pourraient tenter de traverser la route en courant.
Hood a associé le fléau de l'immigrant d'aujourd'hui
à celui de la longue marche des Navajos.
C'est une œuvre activiste brillante.
Il a été très minutieux
dans son idée d'utiliser une petite fille avec des couettes, par exemple,
car il a pensé que les automobilistes éprouveraient plus de sympathie
et il a utilisé la silhouette du leader pour les droits civils Cesar Chavez
pour créer la tête du père.
Je voulais m'appuyer sur le brio de ce panneau
pour attirer l'attention sur la séparation des enfants à la frontière
et j'ai agi de façon très simple.
J'ai tourné les familles pour qu'elles se fassent face.
Les dernières semaines,
j'ai eu l'opportunité de ramener ce panneau sur l'autoroute
pour raconter une histoire,
l'histoire des relations que nous devrions rétablir
et un rappel que nous devrions créer
des états réunis et non pas des états divisés.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)